Un souffle,
Un souffle de cachalot dans le mystère
de l'océan Indien.
Au royaume du grand bleu.
Grand Bleu ne veut rien dire.
L'essentiel de l'océan, c'est le grand noir.
Les abysses.
Dans la nuit éternelle,
une invitation au voyage vertical.
Aucun humain n'a jamais plongé jusqu'ici.
Aucun ni descendra jamais,
sauf dans une machine.
Pendant des millions d'années,
les ténèbres et le froid du grand dessous
sont restés une énigme.
Au pays du calmar géant,
voici l'histoire d'un clan de cétacés géants,
le peuple du grand Noir.
Les cachalots, les grosses têtes,
Les plus gros cerveaux du monde.
Une espèce intelligente et sociable,
qui parle une langue
dont les mots sont des clics.
Voici cinq siècles, l'homme a doublé le cap
des tempêtes,
Et c'est risquer dans ces parages de terreur,
Qu'il a nommé 40ᵉ rugissants.
Mais les abysses et leurs créatures
lui restent ignorés.
Les cachalots connaissent
cet univers fantastique.
Ils plongent à 3000 mètres,
et tiennent 1h30 en apnée.
Au dessous de 200 mètres,
l'œil humain ne voit plus que du noir.
Les seules lumières sont celles
des créatures bio luminescentes,
comme cette méduse peigne.
Nos lampes électrique révèleront
quelques secrets du grand noir.
Les conditions de vie dans
les abysses sont effroyables.
L'obscurité totale.
Une eau glaciale, entre zéro et un degrés.
100 fois la pression de l'atmosphère
à 1000 mètres sous la surface.
En l'absence de lumière du soleil,
pas de photosynthèse, donc pas de plantes.
Au dessous de 200 mètres,
toute créature est animale.
Parmi ceux-ci, le poulpe à oreilles n'agite
pas ses oreilles mais ses nageoires.
Un prodigieux voyage dans le corps
ou dans le cœur de la mer.
Une odyssée à la fois horizontale et verticale.
L'histoire de ce clan de cachalots commence
voici plus de deux siècles,
près d'un archipel perdu de l'océan Indien,
sur la route de l'Antarctique.
Ces terres sont si glaciales et si ventée
qu'aucun arbre n'y pousse.
Ici, il pleut ou neige 300 jours par an.
Voici deux siècles, une bande de cachalots
mals a établi son royaume autour de cet archipel.
Les grands mâles s'accommodent des
eaux froides, riches en nourriture.
Les femelles, soucieuses du confort de leur
bébé, préfèrent la tiédeur des tropiques.
Le clan des mâles se tient toujours au large
pour une excellente raison,
Le long des côtes patrouille
les pires ennemis des cachalots.
Les baleines tueuses, les orques.
L'orque mâle brandit un aileron
dorsale haut d'1m80,
Deux fois moins chez sa compagne.
Les orques vivent en troupe familiale,
guidée par une femelle expérimentée,
qu'on appelle la matriarche.
La matriarche a de bons yeux,
Mais voit encore mieux avec ses oreilles.
Même dans la nuit des profondeurs, son sonar lui
offre une image acoustique précise de l'environnement.
La troupe avance telle une brigade en campagne.
Elle patrouille le long des côtes
pour y déceler la moindre activité.
Par exemple le passage des manchots royaux.
On en compte 2 millions sur l'archipel.
Pour nourrir leurs poussins, les adultes effectuent
d'incessants va et vient entre la terre et la houle.
Chez les orques, la matriarche a gravé
dans sa mémoire l'itinéraire des oiseaux.
Les mâles en ont fait autant.
Les manchots ne manquent
pas non plus de mémoire.
Une formule y est inscrite en lettres de sang.
Orque égale mort.
Sous l'eau, les faibles vibrations des manchots
se confondent avec le vacarme ambiant.
Pour localiser les oiseaux, la matriarche attend
qu'ils crèvent bruyamment la surface pour respirer.
Les orques sont puissantes.
Jusqu'ici, on n'avait pas compris la manière dont
elles s'y prennent pour dévorer les manchots.
Elles écrasent l'oiseau entre langue et palais.
Afin d'en faire gicler la chair et les tripes.
Elle abandonne la carcasse
comme un tube de ketchup vide.
La matriarche transmet ce savoir à sa fille
qui deviendra un jour l'âme de la troupe.
Voici deux siècles, à distance respectueuse
de ces terreurs en noir et blanc,
les cachalots coulent une existence paisible.
Mais un jour, la ligne d'horizon
accouche de visiteurs inquiétants.
Ces intrus viennent d'un univers que
les cachalots ne peuvent pas soupçonner.
Ce sont des hommes, bien sûr,
mais pas n'importe lesquels.
Partis de la Nouvelle Angleterre,
Profession : baleinier.
Les Américains ont lu les récits du français
Marion Dufresne, en 1772,
fasciné par la légende du grand continent austral,
ce marin double le cap de Bonne-Espérance.
À 46 degrés de latitude sud, dans une mer
qu'il décrit comme grouillante de monstres,
il trouve cet archipel.
Il en prend possession pour la France et lui
donne le nom du second de son navire, Crozet.
Les Américains mettent à profit la découverte
de ces terres subantarctiques,
trop lointaines pour être surveillées.
On les appelle les south sea men,
les hommes des mers du Sud.
À l'époque, l'huile de baleine éclaire le monde.
Etrangers,
chante-nous une chanson pour fêter ça !
Là, elle souffle ! Droit devant !
On y va. Doucement.
Doucement, j'ai dit !
La forme du souffle du cachalot le trahit.
C'est le seul cétacé qui envoie
son panache par un unique évent.
Du côté gauche et à 45 degrés vers l'avant.
Descendez ma chaloupe ! À bâbord !
Barbe Noire, moussaillon, avec moi !
Rame tribord mon garçon.
Les baleiniers savent qu'après
chaque plongée profonde,
Le cachalot a besoin de dix minutes
en surface pour renouveler son oxygène.
En outre, à cause de ses yeux latéraux,
le champ de vision du cétacé présente des angles
morts vers l'avant et vers l'arrière.
Le harponneur tente de piquer la baleine
derrière la première bosse de son dos.
Ne vous en faites pas les gars, on ne bougera pas
de là tant qu'on ne lui aura pas fait la peau.
Là, il souffle à 2h !
Plus pour très longtemps !
Attention, il nous échappe !
Le cachalot !
Il a sondé pour plus d'une heure pour
réapparaître à plusieurs milles d'ici.
Il y en a d'autres pas loin. Cap au sud !
Le cachalot isolé appelle
ses congénères à la rescousse.
Les cris d'alerte qu'il émet
et qu'on qualifie de coda,
Comptent parmi les plus puissants
du règne animal.
Sous l'eau, on les entend
à des dizaines de kilomètres.
Message reçu.
Une centaine de mâles constituent la troupe
qu'on pourrait baptiser le gang de creuser.
Chez les cachalots,
la solidarité n'est pas un vain mot.
Écopez, bon dieu !
Il a les mains en sang !
Au temps de Moby Dick, les déferlantes des 40 ème
rugissants sont durs aussi pour les baleiniers.
Les cétacés écoutent à la fois
leur instinct et leur intelligence.
Le mot d'ordre est de rester groupés.
Pour se nourrir comme pour affronter les périls.
À l'inverse, les humains
cherchent à disloquer le clan,
à isoler un individu.
Question de patience et d'expérience.
Lorsque le cachalot dominant
a identifié un danger,
Il l'affronte en combat frontal comme
un rival à la saison des amours.
En assimilant la chaloupe à un concurrent,
celui-ci signe sa perte.
Aussi longtemps que les cachalots
maintiennent leur cohésion,
les hommes et leur esquif ne pèsent pas lourd.
Mais en sondant, les géants abandonnent
leur leader à une mort inéluctable.
Je le vois, capitaine.
Elle est encore partie.
Elle ne bougera pas de là tant qu'on ne lui
aura pas fait la peau !
Là, elle souffle, droit devant !
Doucement les grands. tout doux.
Maintenant ! Montrez-lui !
Harponneur, pique lui la peau.
Envoie-le au diable !
Au temps de Moby Dick,
des centaines de cachalots sont allés
sur ces plages pour y être débités.
Ont fait fondre leur lard,
qu'on met en tonneaux.
Dans la langue des marins,
un cachalot de taille moyenne est un 40 barriques.
Les baleiniers apprennent aussi à dépecer
leur prise à flanc de navires,
et à traiter la graisse à bord.
Faute de chair à harpon,
le grand massacre s'achève
au début du XXᵉ siècle.
Le gang de creuser a été anéanti.
Il faut attendre le moratoire de 1986 pour
que la chasse à la baleine soit enfin prohibée,
dans l'océan Indien comme ailleurs.
Un royaume que visitent les descendants
des rescapés du massacre.
Ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les sauvés des eaux.
Dans les abysses, le premier maillon de la
chaîne alimentaire tombe de la surface,
sous forme de débris en tout genre.
Le corps de ce cachalot mort
fertilise les fonds locaux,
dépouillé par les baleiniers de sa chair, de
son lard et du précieux spermaceti de sa tête,
la carcasse a coulé.
Une aubaine pour les nettoyeurs.
Au cimetière des abysses,
les recycleurs prospèrent.
Comme ce corail noir qu'on dirait
fleuri de polypes roses.
Ce poisson trépied.
Ce poisson crapaud antarctique.
Ou ce concombre de mer atypique,
qui nage en pleine eau au lieu
de se traîner sur le sédiment.
La masse des détritus nourrit
une armada d'araignées de mer.
Ces nettoyeuse se rassemblent par millions.
Elles attirent des prédateurs contre lesquels elles
n'ont d'autre défense que leur carapace épineuse.
Parmi les amateurs de crustacés
figure le grenadier,
un cousin de la morue.
Sa queue effilée lui vaut
le sobriquet de poisson rat.
Il communique avec ses congénères
grâce à une vessie natatoire,
Qu'il fait résonner comme un tambour.
Cet organe le rend vulnérable aux
variations de pression liées à la profondeur.
La chimère dite aussi queue de rat
est bien différente.
Elle n'a pas de vessie natatoire.
C'est un fossile vivant, un poisson
cartilagineux ancestral, proche des requins.
Dans la pente abyssale à plus
de 500 mètres sous la surface,
La chimère se goberge d'alevins.
Ces petits poissons comptent sur le nombre
pour désorienter leurs prédateurs.
Pour les alevins, le plus terrible ennemi
n'est pas la chimère.
Ils possèdent des dents acérées et de gros
yeux qui détectent le moindre reflet.
Il peut peser 300 kilos
et mesurer 1m80 de longueur.
Ce chasseur implacable,
c'est la légine.
La légine partage ces banquets de petits
poissons avec le calmar.
Ce dernier saisit ses proies en projetant
vers l'avant deux tentacules spécialisées.
Il arrive aussi que le calmar
figure au menu de la légine.
Les cachalots se nourrissent
avant tout de calmars.
Ils les trouvent grâce à leur sonar.
Ils émettent des clics que la bosse de leur
tête amplifie et dirigent.
Ce melon contient une huile
très fine appelée Spermaceti,
par les baleiniers qui l'avaient
prise pour du sperme.
Les ondes sont réfléchies par les obstacles,
le cerveau analyse les données et c'est ainsi
que le cachalot voit le monde,
avec ses oreilles.
Pour la première fois à la fin du XXᵉ siècle,
les cachalots de Crozet,
perçoivent des émissions sonar
qui ne proviennent pas de cétacés.
Ces clics sortent de monstre de métal où
ont pris place, non pas des baleiniers,
mais des scientifiques.
Des océanographes français occupés
à lever une carte des reliefs sous marins.
La carte des abysses, les cétacés de Crozet
l'ont depuis longtemps dans la tête.
En bien plus précis.
À certaines époques, quelques uns d'entre
eux ont en effet le privilège,
De gagner les eaux chauds des tropiques
où se tiennent les troupes de femelles.
Grâce à l'arrêt de la chasse à la baleine,
c'est ici, au secret du canal du Mozambique,
que le gang de Crozet s'est reformé.
Voici le fief d'une grande femelle.
Une chef, une matriarche,
Entourée de ses filles,
petites filles et des jeunes
de la famille au sens large.
Les sociétés de cachalots sont matriarcale.
Malgré leurs 18 mètres
de longueur et leurs 60 tonnes,
Contre 12 mètres
et 15 tonnes pour les femelles,
les mâles adultes en sont exclus.
De temps à autre, l'un d'eux,
Un dominant qui a conquis sa place de haute lutte,
vient présenter ses hommages à une
belle afin de perpétuer l'espèce.
Plaisir de la crèche,
lorsqu'une mère cachalot sonde
et part chasser aux abysses,
Une tante ou une grande sœur
surveille le bébé.
Les petits apprennent la signification
des clics, des coda,
des sifflements de leur espèce,
qui constituent un langage.
Au même titre que le code morse des humains,
ou les dialogues de tambours des villages africains.
À la puberté, le jeune mâle est invité à
oublier la troupe matriarcale.
Tabou de l'inceste.
Il s'associe avec d'autres adolescents qui constituent
des bandes de célibataires ou bacheliers.
À l'âge adulte, cap au sud.
Vers le royaume de Crozet.
Aujourd'hui, les eaux qui cernent cet archipel,
ne résonnent plus des cris de harponneur,
comme au temps de Moby Dick.
Les fonds répercutent
d'étranges sonorités métalliques.
Ces tintements attirent
les hôtes du grand noir.
Du moins ceux qui peuvent nager
comme le poulpe à oreilles.
Le restaurant et le menu consistent en de
longs filins garnis d'hameçon tombés du ciel.
La chimère réside devant ces objets
qu'elle n'a jamais rencontrés.
Même dans le noir, le cachalot
peut observer la scène.
Il la voit avec ses oreilles.
Des ancres entraînent vers le fond des
kilomètres de longues lignes au palangre.
Nombreux sont ceux que
les hameçons intéressent.
Cette offrande tombée de la surface passionne
un singulier personnage des abysses.
Le calmar abralia.
Le petit peuple du Grand Noir
se presse pour profiter de l'aubaine.
Le restaurant n'est ouvert
que quelques heures.
Les calmars boudent le menu,
cela leur sauve la vie.
Tel, celles toutes nos antarctiques
surnommés calmars volants.
Les céphalopodes se font
rarement prendre au piège.
Ils entreprennent chaque soir des migrations
verticales de plusieurs centaines de mètres.
Ils gagnent la surface en quête de chair fraîche,
puis redescendent à l'aube.
Mais le dangereux gros cousin
est aussi mangeur de calmars.
Rien n'est jamais simple en mer.
À la surface, le comité d'accueil
n'est pas vraiment amical.
Mais qui sont donc, là haut,
ceux qui jettent ces longues lignes ?
Dans leur usine flottante,
les pêcheurs travaillent dur.
Vite, toujours plus vite.
La saison est si courte.
Afin de ne pas perdre leur ligne
dans l'infini de la houle,
Les marins y élinguent des bouées
munies d'un émetteur radar.
Toute cette agitation éveille l'attention
des pires ennemis du cachalot.
Elles détectent un bruit d'hélice à 10 milles.
Elles sont curieuses et comprennent tout très vite.
Elles se parlent dans un dialecte de
clics, de sifflements et de grincements.
Les orques.
Les orques arrivent,
menées par leur matriarche.
Elles ne consacrent que 10%
de leur temps à chasser.
Le reste se passe de dialogue, en caresse,
en sieste ou en jeux.
Cette bouée décoratif ferait un excellent jouet.
Les croqueuses de manchots ne plonge pas
aussi bien que les cachalots.
Mais l'arrivée des palangriers
modifie les comportements animaux.
Les hélices attirent le petit peuple
des 40ᵉ rugissants.
Peu connues des hommes,
voici les dauphins porte croix.
Endémique de ces latitudes.
On les appelle aussi sablier.
Le dessin de leurs flancs rappelle
le symbole du temps qui passe.
Dans l'immensité monotone de la mer,
tout devient jeu,
Y compris la rencontre inopinée
de porte croix,
avec un sous marin biologique
de la taille d'un semi-remorque.
Le grand cachalot.
Grâce au moratoire sur
la chasse à la baleine,
une centaine de cachalots mâles
jouissent à nouveau en liberté,
de la sauvage splendeur des Crozets.
Ils ne sont plus contraints de fuir les
humains, mais tenter de les suivre.
Pourquoi se demandent-ils peut-être,
Faut-il que les orques pointent
l'aileron dans cette harmonie ?
Aurait-elle perdu le goût du manchot ?
Elles ont une réputation de tueuse. Elles
pourraient attaquer même si leur grand cousin,
sont 3 fois plus longs
et 20 fois plus lourd qu'elles.
Comme les cachalots, elles sont une
centaine à fréquenter l'archipel des Crozet,
mais elles n'en bougent pas.
Elles sont sédentaires.
Pour l'instant,
elles ignorent leurs parents cétacés.
On dirait qu'elle attendent quelque chose.
La matriarche sait quoi.
Elle entraîne sa famille dans le sillage du
navire jusqu'à ce que les marins repêche la bouée.
Sitôt celle-ci crochetée,
La dominante prend son souffle
et descend le long de la ligne.
Incroyable ! Les orques inspectent
les palangres des pêcheurs.
Cette fois ci, pas de chance.
Rien sur les hameçons.
Les orques ont compris que les hommes viennent
ici traquer des proies délicieuses,
mais qui vivent bien
trop profond pour elles.
Elles ont la ferme intention d'en profiter,
si ce n'est pas l'intelligence.
Un cachalot aurait pu leur dire
qu'il n'y avait rien sur les leurres.
Les cachalots plongent beaucoup
mieux que les orques.
Celles-ci s'arrêtent vers 300 mètres,
en dessous rien à craindre.
Le cachalot descend dix fois plus bas.
1h30 de rêve au grand noir.
Rien au bout des lignes.
Sale journée pour les palans grillés.
Mais aussi pour les cachalots qui doivent
se rabattre sur un autre navire.
On compte jusqu'à six bateaux de pêche
à la fois dans les eaux des Crozet.
Ils ont tous la même silhouette.
Mais chacun sa couleur.
Les hommes n'apprécient guère les cachalots mais
ils maudisent bien davantage les orques,
Qui viennent sans vergogne,
voler le fruit de leur travail.
Seule solution, en avant toute !
Et tenter de semer les pillardes, surpris
d'un détour de plusieurs dizaines de milles.
Problème, à peine le palengrier blanc
a-t-il entamé la manœuvre,
que déjà les orques l'ont rejoint.
Elles n'ont pas l'air
de vouloir lâcher prise.
Sur ces terres de désolation, les dépressions
s'enchaînent au rythme effréné,
De deux ou trois par semaine.
Au Crozet, les vents
se déchaînent à plus de 200 km/h.
À cette vitesse, la nature remet
en question ses propres lois.
Les nuages rampent sur la terre.
Les cascades tombent vers le ciel.
Et la terre se fait nuages.
Poussée par des vents d'ouest
qu'aucun obstacle ne freine,
La grande houle de l'océan Austral tourne.
Tourne autour de l'Antarctique
et se déchire sur les falaises,
en levant les plus colossales
vagues du monde.
Les tourbillons aériens apportent aussi
de savoureuses odeurs de poissons.
Chacun tente de repérer un bruit lointain
parmi les ondes de tempête.
L'indice d'un restaurant flottant.
Premiers arrivés, premiers servis.
Les oiseaux de mer et les orques bien sûr.
Profiter du travail des palangriers,
fait partie de la nouvelle culture
des orques de Crozets.
La matriarche en incarne à la fois
l'instigatrice et l'institutrice.
Les mâles ne participent à rien.
Le pacha ne se donne même
pas la peine d'aller voir.
Il attend en surface que
les femelles viennent le nourrir.
Le trésor que les hommes cherchent ici,
c'est celui du grand noir.
Les grenadiers, les chimères
et surtout les légines,
les plus prisés, donc les plus chers.
Les jours fastes, le monstre de métal avale
jusqu'à cinq tonnes de ces poissons.
Le grand cachalot finit par arriver,
à son train.
Les orques semblent plus agressifs
que la fois précédente.
Deux raisons à cela.
Les lignes sont maintenant
bien garni et il est seul.
La matriarche des orques a la ferme intention
de réserver l'accès du restaurant à sa famille.
Elle rassemble sa troupe.
Le cachalot connaît ce manège.
Cela s'appelle de l'intimidation.
Il se place le long du navire,
à un côté de moins surveillé.
Les orques tentent de se glisser
entre le bateau et lui.
La matriarche le suit comme son ombre pour
indiquer sa position à son clan.
Stratégie imparable.
Une escouade lui interdit toute fuite.
La matriarche et sa famille déploient le
grand jeu, pour ruiner le moral de l'adversaire.
Détonation sous marines,
bulles crachées par l'évents.
Le cachalot résiste.
Mais il est cerné.
Il essaie de suivre l'exemple de ses aïeux
face aux baleiniers.
Il appelle son clan à la rescousse.
Hélas, personne à moins de dix kilomètres
pour détecter ses cris.
Il reste seul.
Face à la meute en uniforme noir et blanc,
sa taille et son poids deviennent un handicap.
L'orque mâle l'empêche de sonder.
Le blocus est partout.
Même en dessous.
Comme les baleiniers jadis,
les orques visent l'angle mort.
Seule parade, tenter le grand
coup de queue puis décrocher.
Raté.
Elles sont trop rapides, trop
nombreuses, trop bruyantes.
On dirait qu'elles ont gagné.
Reste une carte à jouer au géant noir.
Profiter d'un instant d'inattention du mâle
et sonder le plus profondément possible.
C'est parti.
Les orques ont eu ce qu'elle voulait.
Elles fêtent l'événement.
Dans la nature, les puissants
prédateurs se défient.
Mais passent rarement à l'acte.
Une blessure aurait de trop graves conséquences.
Le cachalot n'allait pas risqué
sa santé pour quelque légines,
alors que les abysses lui offrent
généreusement les deux tonnes de nourriture,
Dont il a besoin chaque jour.
Les palangriers peuvent le remercier.
Il a un peu retardé le pillage.
Mais le banquet des orcs recommence.
Les orques font même la fine bouche
lorsque la légine n'est pas au menu.
Et voici le dessert du Pacha.
Une récompense que guettaient
d'autres profiteurs,
Comme ces pétrels à menton blanc.
Les poissons abyssaux ne font pas partie du
régime alimentaire normal des orques,
ou des oiseaux marins comme
le pétrel géant ou l'albatros royal.
En jetant ces palangres dans le grand noir,
L'homme bouleverse la donne écologique.
Nombre de locataires des mers australes ont
modifié leur comportement pour accéder à cette manne.
Le bateau de pêche devient une oasis
artificielle pour opportunistes et charognards.
Une sorte de fontaine
miraculeuse de protéines.
Cela peut-il durer ?
Est-il possible de briser ou de raccourcir une chaîne
écologique majeure sans en payer le prix ?
Dans les eaux des Crozets,
des quotas de pêche ont été instaurés.
Encore faut-il se donner les
moyens d'empêcher le braconnage.
Quant au cachalot, rien ne prouve qu'il soit
innocent de tout chapardage sur les longues lignes.
Secret bien gardé.
Si le cachalot pouvait parler et il parle
dans sa langue cliquetée,
Il dirait qu'il a d'autres secrets à confier.
En tant que membre du club très fermé
des visiteurs du Grand Noir,
il observe que les équilibres écologiques
changent très vite dans les profondeurs.
Des tonnes de légines en moins
dans les abysses.
C'est autant de menaces envolées pour les calmars.
Les mollusques peuvent se reproduire, vieillir
tranquille et atteindre des dimensions colossales.
À l'exemple de ce gonatus.
Le plus grand céphalopode jamais
filmé vivant dans son milieu.
Longue de 30 cm.
Les coquilles de claps géant
de l'arrière plan,
Permettent d'estimer la taille
du mollusque à 3m50.
Au Crozet, les palangriers récoltent
6500 tonnes de légines par an.
Lesquels que 100 cachalots de l'archipel,
engloutissent dix fois plus de nourriture.
Entre autres, cette chimère à long rostre,
ou cet autre gonatus.
On a découvert dans l'estomac des cachalots,
des animaux surarmés,
comme le poisson vipère.
Mais pas la moindre trace
de blessure sur la proie.
Cela signifie que les grands cétacés capturent
leurs proies en émettant des trains de clics,
D'une telle intensité que celle-ci
reste clouée sur place.
Le cachalot utilise une arme absolue,
Le cri qui tue.
C'est un des secrets du grand Noir.
De ceux dont les hommes n'entendront jamais parler,
parce qu'ils appartiennent à un autre monde.